EVERYTHING WE LEARNED ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED THAT NIGHT.
SO STAY TUNED.
I WANT TO TURN TO THE FORMER NBA
PLAYER AND BASKETBALL HALL OF
FAMER WHO SAYS THAT HE WAS
TURNED AWAY FROM A RESTAURANT
BECAUSE OF THE COLOR OF HIS
SKIN.
DOMINIQUE WILKINS, VICE
PRESIDENT FOR THE NBA TEAM THE
ATLANTA HAWKS, SAID HE WAS
TURNED AWAY FROM A RESTAURANT IN
ATLANTA OVER THE WEEKEND ADDING
THAT HE HAS NEVER BEFORE FACED
PREJUDICE WHEN DINING OUT.
HE JOINS ME NOW.
GOOD EVENING.
IT'S BEEN A WHILE.
>> IT'S BEEN A WHILE, MAN.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
IT'S BEEN A LONG TIME.
UNFORTUNATE TO COME ON -- YEAH,
YEAH, ABSOLUTELY, MAN.
UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE TO COME
TALK ABOUT SOMETHING LIKE THIS.
IT WAS VERY UNFORTUNATE THAT I
HAD TO EXPERIENCE THAT WITH A
FRIEND OF MINE.
>> LET ME EXPLAIN THE STORY
BEFORE YOU GO INTO THAT.
SO AT FIRST, THE RESTAURANT TOLD
YOU, NO TABLES WERE AVAILABLE.
THEN YOU SAID YOU WERE -- THEY
SAID THAT YOU WERE NOT DRESSED
FASHIONABLY ENOUGH.
OKAY.
SO NOW TELL ME WHAT HAPPENED.
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, WE WERE
GOING THROUGH RESTAURANT.
WHEN WE WENT THROUGH DOOR THERE
WERE TWO OR THREE PEOPLE IN THE
FRONT.
THEY LOOKED US UP AND DOWN AND
SIZED US UP.
IT WAS KIND OF STRANGE.
I SAID WE ON LIKE THE SIT DOWN
OUTSIDE AND HAVE LUNCH.
AND THEY LOOKED ME UP AND DOWN
AGAIN AND SAID WE DON'T HAVE ANY
RESERVATIONS AVAILABLE.
I'M LOOKING OUTSIDE, IT'S LUNCH
TIME, 1:00, AND THERE ARE A TON
OF TABLES OUTSIDE, EMPTY.
SO WE WOULD SAID THIS DOESN'T
MAKE SENSE.
I'M DRESSED BETTER THAN MOST OF
THE GUYS IN THERE.
HAD A NICE BELOW THE SHIRT LONG
CARGO BLACK PANTS WITH NICE
SNEAKERS.
TO THE LEFT OF ME THERE WERE
THREE WHITE GUYS WITH SHORTS,
T-SHIRTS AND SNEAKERS.
AND THEM, GIVE ME A MINUTE.
WE'LL SEAT NEW SECOND.
AND I AM, WELL, THERE DOESN'T
MAKE ESSENTIAL.
YOU HAVE ALL THESE TABLES.
WE DON'T HAVE ANYTHING
AVAILABLE.
AND HE SAID, WE'RE TRYING TO
KEEP A LEVEL OF ELEGANCE IN OUR
RESTAURANT SO WE CAN'T SEAT YOU.
SO I LEFT.
MY GIRLFRIEND WENT BACK AND
SAID, MR. WILKINS, WHAT IS YOUR
CRITERIA OF DRESS CODE?
HE WAS DRESSED BETTER THAN MOST
OF THE PEOPLE IN HERE.
SO HE WAS NOT IN SWEATPANTS OR
WHATEVER YOU WANT TO CALL IT.
IT IS CLEAR, CLEAR ACT OF
DISCRIMINATION.
AND SO I WAS JUST BLOWN AWAY
THAT THEY TURNED ME AWAY.
THEY WERE VERY, VERY NASTY.
>> YOU'RE DOMINIQUE WILKINS.
YOU'RE A LEGEND IN ATLANTA.
BUT IT'S TRUE.
AND I THINK THAT ANY RESTAURANT
IN THE ATLANTA AREA, I'M BEING
HONEST, SHOULD KNOW WHO THE HELL
DOMINIQUE WILKINS IS.
I'M SORRY.
THAT'S THE TRUTH.
>> BUT IT SHOULDN'T HAPPEN --
>> YOU'RE RIGHT.
I GET THAT.
IT SHOULDN'T HAPPEN TO ANYBODY.
BUT STILL, THAT WAS ON THE STAFF
OF PROBABLY YOUNG PEOPLE WHO
DON'T KNOW THEIR YOU KNOW WHAT
FROM A YOU KNOW WHAT.
THE RESTAURANT INITIALLY
RELEASED A STATEMENT THAT
FOCUSED ON DRESS CODE.
HERE'S WHAT IT SAID.
TO PROTECT OUR RESTAURANT'S
CULTURE, WE INSTALLED A MINIMUM
STANDARD IN OUR BUSINESS CASUAL
ATTIRE WHICH INCLUDES JEANS AND
SNEAKERS BUT PROHIBIT BASKETBALL
CAPS, BASEBALL CAMS AND ATHLETIC
CLOTHING INCLUDING SWEAT PANTS
AND TOPS.
THOUGH THE DEFINITION OF CASUAL
IS EVER EVOLVING, WE STRIVE TO
MAINTAIN OUR POLICY REQUIREMENTS
DAILY BUT IT ISN'T A PERFECT
SYSTEM.
DRESS CODES AT RESTAURANTS.
IT CAN BE TRICKY.
IT CAN BE ARBITRARY.
THEY CAN BE ENFORCED
INCONSISTENTLY FOR DIFFERENT
PEOPLE.
SO AGAIN, THIS SHOULDN'T HAPPEN
TO ANYONE.
I KNOW YOU SAY, IT DIDN'T MATTER
THAT YOU'RE DOMINIQUE WILKINS.
IT SHOULDN'T HAPPEN TO ANYONE.
WHAT DID YOU THINK OF THIS FIRST
RESPONSE?
>> FIRST OF ALL, I THOUGHT IT
WAS, WASN'T A TIME OF RESPONSE
THAT I THOUGHT WAS EFFICIENT
BECAUSE I THINK THEY LIED A LOT
IN THAT STATEMENT.
THEY RELEASED THE STATEMENT
EARLIER TODAY, BASICALLY
APOLOGIZING FOR WHAT HAPPENED.
AND NOW THEY WANT TO MAKE A LOT
OF CHANGES.
THE REASON WHY I SAID, I FELT
LIKE IT WAS RACISM, BECAUSE I'M
SEEING TWO OR THREE WHITE GUYS
IN SHORTS, T-SHIRTS AND
SNEAKERS.
AND YOU'RE NOT TURNING THEM
AWAY.
AND SO IT FELT LIKE BACK WHEN I
WAS IN HIGH SCHOOL.
I MADE A DECISION TO FURTHER MY
EDUCATION AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
GEORGIA.
EVEN THOUGH IT IS NOT THE SAME,
IT FELT THE SAME.
SO IT WAS VERY, VERY NASTY.
MY FRIEND WENT BACK AND ASKED
THEM, WHY DID YOU DO THAT?
THEY SAID, YOU KNOW, MR.
WILKINS -- THEY SAID WE CAN'T
SEAT HIM.
I HAVE JUST NEVER BEEN -- THE
THING IS DISCRIMINATION HAS MANY
DIFFERENT DISGUISES.
IN THIS CASE, THE DISGUISE IS
THROUGH A DRESS CODE.
I'M NOT THE ONLY CASE OR THE
ONLY PERSON WHO HAD THIS TIME OF
THING HAPPEN.
THIS HAS BEEN A TREND.
HOPEFULLY, I'M HOPING THEY LEARN
FROM THIS AND THAT THEY CAN GET
SOME DIVERSITY AND EQUALITY
TRAINING ON GUARD AGAINST THIS.
WHAT WE DO AS FAR AS PEOPLE
DEALING WITH NEEDS, WITH
INCLUSION.
IT HAS TO BE ADDRESSED AND WE
ADDRESS THOSE THINGS RIGHT NOW.
THESE ARE THE THINGS WE DO AND
THAT IS JUST MIND-BOGGLING TO ME
AT THIS DAY IN THE WORLD, WE
HAVE TO DEAL WITH THIS TIME OF
STUFF.
>> I'M SORRY THAT HAPPENED TO
YOU.
I RESPECT YOU AND LOVE YOU A
LOT.
I MISS SEEING KNEW ATLANTA.
WHAT I DO MISS IS THE GREAT
SEATS WE USED TO HAVE WHEN WE
WERE TURNER DOWN THERE.
LISTEN, THANK YOU.
I APPRECIATE THAT.
I HAVE TO TILL, IN FULL
TRANSPARENCY, I KNOW SOME OF THE
FOLKS WHO OWN THE RESTAURANT.
AND THEY SHOULD DO BETTER.
AND I THINK THAT THEY WILL DO
BETTER AFTER THIS.
AND I THINK THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
MAKE THAT CHANGE HAPPEN.
THEY ARE AN UPSCALE RESTAURANT.
THERE IS ONE HERE, ONE IN PALM
BEACH, ONE IN ATLANTA.
THEY WILL DO BETTER AND I THANK